Let's talk about some other options for
relationships beyond one-to-many, starting with one-to-one.
One-to-one relationships generally come up when
two dimension tables have related qualitative data.
They have some of the same benefits of a one-to-many relationship.
They're straightforward and predictable and easy to
understand for end-users as well as within the data model itself.
But the question you always have to ask is,
do you actually need a one-to-one relationship
or is what you're going for actually a merge table?
In this instance, for example,
we have two separate tables,
first with the first and last name of customers
and the other with zip code and city information.
If we want to see Sam Cooke associated with his address,
we can do that with a one-to-one relationship that's bidirectional,
but the key limitating point is what if you wanted to see
all of your customers by city with their names underneath,
that would be a hierarchy situation that you can't do when
you have a one-to-one relationship as opposed to a merge table.
To me, this is a much better solution,
merging them together gives you more flexibility to ensure that you can create
those hierarchies if you need to and you don't lose anything by creating this merging.
I'm sure there must be rare instances where
a one-to-one relationship makes the most practical sense,
but I've yet to run into them personally.
Invariably, I avoid creating
a one-to-one relationship and merge the two tables together in Power Query instead.
Many-to-many relationships.
Just don't. Let's move on, I'm kidding.
Let's talk about it.
When you have a many-to-many relationship,
you might have a single product like a smartphone.
You might group this under communications devices and personal technology.
Even though it's a single entity,
it belongs to two different groups, two different hierarchies.
This is an example of a true many-to-many.
Let's see what this might look like with some actual data tables.
Here we can see that each of the iPhones in the sales table
is associated with multiple product dimension types,
both a communications product type and a personal technology product type.
The reverse is also true.
Each of the product dimensions associated with the iPhones
is also attributable to multiple sales.
The problem with many-to-many relationships is that they tend to
be confusing for both your end users and the data model itself.
Especially if you aren't 100 percent confident on how you want that data to perform.
Many-to-many relationships, leverage bidirectional filtering.
The logic and flow in both directions as you add additional tables.
This can result in ambiguities that Power BI doesn't know how they handle.
For example, if we're adding
a single additional dimension table
and you try to connect it to both of these fact tables,
you'll find that the bidirectional nature
of the relationship between the two fact tables.
To facilitate that many-to-many relationship means that you can only have one of
the two-dimension relationships active with the other remaining inactive.
The short answer when it comes to
many-to-many relationships is this is another instance of can versus should.
You can use a many-to-many relationship.
But best practice is to avoid them whenever possible.
I personally have never come up with a good instance
where I truly need a many-to-many relationship in my work,
the potential issues include unpredictable results,
either because you don't understand
the data model structure or you understand it perfectly,
but your end users are trying to use it differently from
how you intended those different relationships to work.
As I mentioned, it's very confusing for end-users.
Even if you give them clear guidance,
they are likely to come to
their own conclusions and they might not be the ones that you mean for them too.
There's a potential for performance issues as well.